foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Harry's death at the hands of
Voldemort in the Deathly Hallows more
specifically we're going to be diving in
and dissecting the nuances of how it
happened why it happened and how Harry
was able to come back to life
to set the scene we're in the Forbidden
Forest and Harry comes face to face with
Voldemort once again however unlike
previous confrontations from his meeting
with a fragmented Voldemort attached to
Professor Quirrell to their jewel in the
graveyard of little Angleton this time
Harry does not intend to defend himself
or fight back he's come to die fans of
the book will remember the chapter as
the aptly named the forest again and
movie lovers will certainly know this
scene as the one right after Harry sees
his dead loved ones through the magic of
the Resurrection Stone one of the three
fabled Deathly Hallows Voldemort and his
followers are waiting for Harry to turn
himself over a deal Voldemort has
proposed in exchange for the safety of
the other Wizards who've been fighting
alongside Harry in the Battle of
Hogwarts I thought he would come said
Voldemort in his high clear voice his
eyes and the leaping Flames I expected
him to come I was it seems mistaken said
Voldemort you weren't Harry said it as
loudly as he could with all the force he
could Master he did not want to sound
afraid at that moment he felt that
nobody mattered but Voldemort it was
just the two of them Harry Potter
Voldemort said very softly his voice
might have been part of the Spitting
Fire the boy who lived none of the Death
Eaters moved they were waiting
everything was waiting Hagrid was
struggling and Bellatrix was panting and
Harry thought inexplicably of Ginny and
her blazing look and the feel of her
lips on his Voldemort had raised his
wand his head was still tilted to one
side like a curious child wondering what
would happen if he proceeded Harry
looked back into the red eyes and wanted
it to happen now and quickly while he
could still stand before he lost control
before he portrayed fear
he saw the mouth move in the flash of
green light and everything was gone okay
so what happened well it appears that
Harry gets hit with Avada Kedavra the
killing curse it's well reinforced in
Harry Potter that Avada cadaver a
terrible dark curve that is known to
emit a blindingly intense green bolt of
light kills people in fact the only
function of the spell is to kill so how
is Harry able to come back from it
one could argue that Avada Kedavra is
never actually written on the page but
to that I say don't be ridiculous the
next thing we see is Harry waking up in
a strange place a place unlike anything
else we had seen previously he lay in a
bright Mist though it was not like Mist
he had ever experienced before his
surroundings were not hidden by cloudy
Vapor rather the Cloudy Vapor had not
yet formed into surroundings the floor
in which he lay seemed to be white
neither warm nor cold but simply there a
flat blank something on which to be his
environment was completely surreal and
Harry had lost all of his bearings in
fact he had no idea of what he was
experiencing was real or just a figment
of his imagination tell me one last
thing is this real or has this been
happening inside my head to which
Dumbledore replies of course it is
happening inside your head Harry but why
on Earth should that mean that it is not
real
Harry after a minor adjustment to his
surroundings also noticed that the
emails had begun to form in the shape of
King's cross station where he first
departed to Hogwarts so many years ago
but Harry wasn't truly at King's cross
so where was he as it turns out he was
in limbo limbo in many religions can be
described as the Border Place Between
Heaven and Hell where souls go before
moving on to the afterlife it's never
explicitly described in the book whether
or not all souls in the Harry Potter
Universe go through this point in limbo
however Harry certainly made it and it's
all to do with his connection to
Voldemort when we look at Harry in this
strange new environment what we're
witnessing is Harry's soul and this
lines up perfectly with the way he died
one theory for how Avada Kedavra kills
you is that it rips the soul from the
body so while Harry's physical form
remained in the Forbidden Forest his
soul was now relocated to somewhere
completely different of course there
always lies the possibility that all of
this could still simply be magic a mind
trick or some form of magic we have
never seen before but then Dumbledore
who we all know to be dead approaches
him
it would be reasonable at this point to
conclude that Harry himself is dead that
he has come to a sort of afterlife in
fact that's the conclusion that Harry
comes to as well having the following
exchange with his old Headmaster
but you're dead said Harry oh yes it's a
Dumbledore matter of factly then I'm
dead too ah said Dumbledore smiling
still more broadly that is the question
isn't it on the whole dear boy I think
not here's why Harry's situation in
limbo was more complicated he wasn't
actually dead during Harry's talk with
Dumbledore Dumbledore explains that
Harry is in fact very much alive for his
soul was still entirely intact whole so
despite being in limbo Harry was alive
which meant that yes he could choose to
go on to the afterlife but he also had
the much better option of returning to
the land of the living as a whole person
Harry could board the train and go on
or he could just return to where he came
from Harry chose the latter okay but now
you might be wondering how how was Harry
Still Alive Harry wonders the very same
thing but if Voldemort used the killing
curse Harry started again and nobody
died for me this time how can I be alive
I think you know said Dumbledore think
back remember what he did in his
ignorance in his greed and his cruelty
he took my blood said Harry precisely
said Dumbledore he took your blood and
rebuilt his living body with it your
blood in his veins Harry Lilly's
protection inside both of you he
tethered you to life while he lives you
with the seventh horcrux Harry the
horcrux he never meant to make he had
rendered his soul so unstable that it
broke apart when he committed those acts
of unspeakable evil the murder of your
parents the attempted killing of a child
but what escape from that room was even
less than he knew he left more than his
body behind he left part of himself
latched to you the would-be victim who
had survived Harry Never Dies because
his mother's sacrifice the same magic
that has protected him for all his life
is still alive in Lord Voldemort's veins
if we put that together with the fact
that his lifelong lightning bolt scar
has disappeared at least temporarily and
the fact that there is an agonized
creature quietly moaning in the
background it all starts to make sense
Dumbledore all but confirms this Theory
when he assures Harry that the part of
Baltimore soul that was inside of him
was destroyed when Voldemort hit Harry
with the killing curse this time around
saying your soul is whole and completely
your own Harry however I will add this
many fans believe that the child on the
floor of King's cross was in fact the
part of Voldemort's soul that previously
resided within Harry we know that Harry
carried a piece of Voldemort with him
for his entire life and so it seems to
make sense that with Harry dying and
this Soul Shard now destroyed it would
follow him to the afterlife however
though this is close to the answer it's
actually wrong according to JK Rowling
the being stuck in limbo with Harry
wasn't the horcrux within himself but
rather the current state of Voldemort's
Soul what exactly was the mutilated
baby-like creature Harry saw toward
King's cross in chapter 35 of Hallows
I've been asked this a lot it is the
last piece of Soul a Voldemort
possessors when Voldemort attacks Harry
they both fall temporarily unconscious
and both their souls Harry's undamaged
and healthy voldemorts stunted and
maimed appear in the limbo where Harry
meets Dumbledore in essence it's a
representation of Voldemort's maimed
Soul rather than the piece of destroyed
soul that resided within Harry the most
common interpretation of Harry's run-in
with this odd creature vodel lived a
cursed life where he would routinely rip
his own soul apart in pursuit of
immortality and such acts come at a
great cost the pathetic wriggling child
squirming along the floor was all that
was left of Voldemort's Soul now that
we've cleared up the fact that Harry
never actually truly died I think it's
time for me to answer the question of
how he returned from this alternate
plane of existence
essentially because Harry's soul is now
whole and pure he is given the
opportunity to return to his life as
just Harry all he has to do at this
point is choose to go back being that
his version of purgatory is at King's
cross station Dumbledore suggests that
if Harry chooses to move on into death
he would likely board a train and to
carry on but of course Harry chooses to
return to the world of the living in
order to try to finally defeat Voldemort
and help save as many people as he can
from further death and destruction at
this point Dumbledore begins to
disappear into a descending mist and you
may begin to wonder if any of this has
actually happened maybe Harry just hit
his head really hard of course Harry has
this exact same thought asking
Dumbledore one final question before he
completely disappears Harry wants to
know and I can hardly blame him if any
of this was real or if it was only
happening inside his head to which
Dumbledore responds with one of my
all-time favorite lines of course it is
happening inside your head Harry but why
on Earth should that mean that it is not
real and with that we've reached the end
of another video if you enjoy the
content please be sure to like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign